hi we are phillip and jens from otto
since november 2020 we have been working
as part of team archie to explore new
opportunities of information retrieval
systems
the auto group is germany's second
biggest e-commerce player and with 15.6
billion euro turnover one of the biggest
e-commerce player in the world
otto has one of the biggest e-commerce
data science communities in europe with
machine learning being part of almost
all e-commerce capabilities
part of our approach has been developing
a transformer-based semantic search
one of our bigger challenges was the
performance and scalability of our
transformer modules with a target to use
it on our platform a real-time scenario
for transformer models on the highest
load
in total it took us less than one day to
set everything up from our side in the
first step we pushed our models through
the hugging phase model hub
the model's inference we are then
optimized for our hardware by hugging
phase and the result provided in a
docker container that just needed to be
started
the api was callable within a couple of
minutes and we could start our
evaluation process
we trained the roberta model with the
whole product variations of our platform
and the ranking model as downstream
tasks
we were able to reach around 2.3
milliseconds for the feature extraction
task and around 2.4 milliseconds for the
ranking task per data point
this is about 100 times faster than a
non-optimized model on cpu and 10 times
faster than on gpu
batch processing and multi gpu were not
available at the time
we expect these features to contribute
to even better performance especially
for the ranking task
we found the major benefit for us and a
tremendous increase in research and
model evaluation cycles
besides the fact that with infinity for
the first time transformer models can
easily be used in real-time scenarios